to figure out where the parasite goes
one way to do this is to you can
genetically modify the parasite and
genetically modify the mouse and what
you do is you kind of build in a
coincidence detector so what happens is
the mouse itself is genetically modified
every every 90 million times every
single neuron is genetically modified to
have a gene that produces a green
produces green but it's turned off kind
of think of it as like a light switch
that gets turned off and then you can
genetically modify the parasite to be
able to come in and actually kind of
flip this switch and what happens is
that only when the parasite is present
will that neuron that individual neuron
turn fluorescent and green and beautiful
so what this means is that you can take
the mouse and then take its brain and
then look at slide slices of its brain
and actually find two exquisite pinpoint
detail to the individual neuron where
all the green cells are so this is the
moment I previously referenced so what
this is is you can take those 3d 2d
slices and reconstruct it back into a
three-dimensional kind of map of every
single infected neuron in a mouse brain
so this is the first time this was ever
done and I was showing this to people
that have studied oxido for a very very
long time and it was universally
surprised Universal surprise and the
reason is it doesn't look like it goes
anywhere in particular it doesn't look
like it goes to one particular region if
I look between all the different mice
all the different mice have completely
different patterns of this of this
behavior but remember this is actually
kind of perfect in some way in the sense
that it kind of maps on to the behavior
that I that I showed that it was quite
variable so the behavior not everything
there were some animals that had it that
had the parasite that were not afraid to
the cat there were some that had the
parasite that were became less afraid of
the cat so there's a wide range of
behavioral change and the fact that this
parasite kind of goes everywhere
it's actually really good for that type
of for that type of data because what it
means is that maybe what's happening
this parasite is randomly distributing
throughout the brain of its host it gets
into the host and randomly
around and that if and only if it ends
up in a brain region or if and only if
it ends up in one place then maybe the
animal becomes less afraid
[Music]